Yo creo que no puedo ser más Clara.
¿Otra cosa es que me quieran
colocar donde me quieren colocar algunos
o estás en la derecha? No,
pero por sus hechos,
por sus hechos los conoceréis,
no por sus hechos los conoceréis.
Es que estamos en contra de la anistía
y le votamos en contra.
La cuestión prejudicial para nosotros no cambia la la
la situación actual
y las normas europeas no las cambia,
no. Pero eso lo dice usted en nuestra opinión.
¿Yo creo que todo el Mundo vota a partir de 1 opinión
y yo no que no voy a estar
es ni en la derecha ni en la izquierda
y porque yo eh?
Cuando votan a coalición Canaria
votan para que coalición Canaria en el congreso pueda
conseguir cosas.
No sé qué es lo que están delegando,
pero no se pueden transferir las
competencias en migración.
Bueno, pero se las Han transferido
y nosotros yo por lo menos yo.
Yo después de votar hubiera dicho ya haberme
haberme contado esto antes,
pero no. Pero es que yo no he votado
ninguna transferencia de migración,
no porque no lo sabía, pero sí,
pero sí. Las las ha votado de alguna forma.
Las ha votado no,
pero
a lo mejor en el futuro traen
alguna modificación de alguna ley
para cumplir ese acuerdo.
Entonces veremos que votamos